hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
I'm gonna answer a question
do I need to take supplements if I'm
already healthy okay really good
question well the first thing we're
gonna talk about is what is healthy
what does healthy mean does it mean
while not in any medications
I'm not grossly overweight well let's
just take a look the definition of
health should be someone that has
amazing energy great sleep no
inflammation in the body good digestion
good adrenals everything is working and
it's optimum and try to find someone
like that I haven't found anyone like
that so we all have body issues going on
so if your health is really really
perfect and then maybe you know don't
need to supplement but even then it's
very difficult to get food that has all
the nutrients because the soils are so
depleted in America now in other parts
of the world it's much better there's
higher levels of nutrients in food and
different places like for example Africa
people that are actually live in Africa
their teeth are really really strong we
have huge roots good dental structure
because the soils are so rich now if you
were raised on food that was grown on
incredibly fertile soil that's a whole
different conversation but in America
the soil is empty so the food is empty
you can only get so much nutrients from
the food if the soil doesn't provide for
the nutrients now if you had a past
history of eating junk food like myself
I lived on pure sugar until I was
probably 20 22 years old
the only thing green that I ate was
pistachio ice cream and lime green jello
I never even ate a vegetable so my
health was very very bad it caught up
with me
by the way but the point is that your
history has a lot to do with your
current health stress wise environmental
eating junk foods just depriving the
body so yes you're gonna need
supplements to actually support the weak
links that are occurring from the past
problems in your digestion your adrenals
so you have inflammatory conditions
chronic sleep issues let's say you're in
a bad marriage for 10 years and you're
stressed out well your
renals need some support so you're going
to have to add supplements now when
you're doing the keto adaptation where
your body is switching over from fat to
sugar it's really necessary to beef up B
vitamins and trace minerals very
important because you're not going to
get that from the food especially if you
want to avoid various symptoms keto rash
keto flu keto fatigue and all the other
symptoms and then we have the factor of
in the environment we live in a chemical
planet every year there's new chemicals
in the environment you're constantly
being exposed so what's gonna happen
that's going to mess up your endocrine
system your liver and that will prevent
you from absorbing nutrients
encountering the benefits of nutrients
the nutrients and food especially the
phytonutrients are there to dismantle
and clean up these chemicals but if
you're not consuming enough of the right
of vegetables for like cruciferous and
things like that and you're not going to
actually extract those poisons in your
body and then we have just getting our
RTA's or our requirement nutrients I
think a lot of people don't realize how
much food you have to consume to get
your basic necessities like even
potassium you need 4700 milligrams
very rarely will anyone consume enough
vegetables to get that you need 7 to 10
cups so it's virtually almost impossible
to get your basic nutrient requirements
based on the soils based on the
environmental toxicity and also the
current body problems that people have
so I want to give you a quick example of
how I use nutrients on different
conditions here's one right here digest
formula this is an acid to help you
absorb protein and minerals so if your
stomach acid is not strong enough you
can't pull that in so we're not
providing nutrients we're providing the
ability to absorb your nutrients here's
another example right here gall bladder
formula this doesn't have any nutrients
in it it has bile purify bile salts to
help you extract the fat soluble
vitamins from the food that you're
already eating so this those two just
helped absorption this one this targets
the nutrient
for the adrenals to help with stress
especially if you have if your weak link
is adrenal okay and then we have the
night formula for the adrenal - to
support the adrenals in a different way
to help you relax go to sleep so your
energy can start rejuvenating and you
can support the adrenals through a good
night's sleep here's another example of
a stronger adrenal product for those
people that have advanced adrenal
fatigue okay
this product would be more of a
concentrated cruciferous which is a
blend of about 13 different cruciferous
vegetables which help give you a
broad-based spectrum of the foods that
most people don't consume so you can
actually help support a healthy liver
and then we have something called
estrogen balance with dim okay now dim
is a concentrated cruciferous you'd have
to consume 2 pounds of cruciferous to
equal just one pill and the reason I
created this is just because a lot of
people are estrogen dominant and we need
to balance that so that that's what
that's for and then we have this one
called organic raw wheatgrass juice
powder
now when teaspoon of this is equivalent
to about nine to eleven shots of
wheatgrass ok that's an entire tray of
wheatgrass it'd be very difficult to
consume that much food so it's a very
concentrated and the cool thing is the
wheatgrass has grown on a super rich
fertile soil so you get the the benefit
of those trace minerals without the high
heat so everything's under low heat so
we have this super enzyme rich
concentrated superfood and then we have
the electrolyte powder again minerals
trace minerals but a lot of potassium
each teaspoon is a thousand milligrams
our bodies need 4700 milligrams of
potassium every day that's like seven to
ten cups of vegetable not like iceberg
lettuce but high-quality vegetable there
are a few people do that so this allows
people to enhance the diet so I'm just
showing you those to show you that the
purpose of supplements are not
necessarily always to get the nutrients
but to support weak links in the body
and help you absorb the nutrients that
you're already getting from the diet
alright thanks for watching so Karen and
I are going to create some more recipes
but we wanted to know what recipes are
you interested in okay click the link
and let us know